welcome back to las vegas now we are
skating into the three ice hockey
championship tournament uh tomorrow at
the orleans arena and skater pro skater
tj hinsick of team leclaire and three
ico ej johnston you guys are here to
gear us up we're excited gear us up i
should say you look good what am i
wearing right now you're wearing team
mullen the yellow team they have been
probably the top team in the league this
year undeniably but tj's team is
probably going to have something to say
about it tj i saw your face get a little
heated when he mentioned i have to
remember who my team is i mean i have to
agree they've won five five out of eight
weekends so
but tomorrow's a new day and a chance to
knock them off
the pedestal they've been on earlier i
like that i like that attitude even
though they're my team so i'm a little
scared but okay so tell us you know you
brought this here in june you guys were
here to tell us about the announcement
of the tournament and what has happened
since then in a nutshell so we love
vegas as a sports market in the hockey
towns we bookended we started with week
one we're gonna finish our championships
uh we kicked off here and this is uh the
ninth week we've got our top four teams
competing for a million dollar prize wow
it is a very big deal you only got seven
guys on a team so they're splitting up
that money themselves
it's going to be incredibly intense um
the hockey's been getting better and
better and more and more intense i said
on another interview earlier you had
some little slashes and some skirmishes
on the ice now which you didn't get in
the first week we're seeing some of you
right now yeah and you got you know a
few dust ups and i i personally love it
the fans love it and um you know tj has
been one of our our best players
lighting it up scoring some unbelievable
goals for us all season long okay tj so
you're playing tomorrow
what's the strategy what's going through
your mind right now
well i'll tell you to be honest i'm
gonna be pretty nervous i mean i've been
fortunate to play in the nhl in
different leagues throughout my career
but i've never played for this amount of
money yet for one day uh it's gonna be
exciting it's gonna be extremely
competitive uh hopefully our team can
come out on top but uh you're gonna see
some guys uh like ej said maybe blocking
some shots maybe a couple slashes here
and there it's be a little more physical
that has been the first eight weeks but
it's gonna be exciting it's gonna be fun
um and hopefully my team comes out on
top oh hopefully and you said a million
dollars we're playing for a million what
would you do if you won with that money
uh
being one of the uh older guys in the
group i probably would take the family
on a nice vacation especially my wife
you know
it's been a challenging summer being
gone every saturday but uh it's been fun
it's been exciting and if you get the
chance i would take the family on a nice
vacation i love that hello now now i'm
rooting for you i'm supposed to be
playing against you but now i'm rooting
for you tj now ej tell everybody how
they can come join you guys and support
you on the ice tomorrow so uh we're on
uh cbs uh at one o'clock local time but
we also can get tickets at
threeisbut.com
and uh we're
you know uh playing at the orleans arena
so you can come down or go online and
check us out it's going to be fantastic
it's two hours of just hair on fire
track meet hockey it's going to be
electric i love it all right ej tj good
luck tomorrow have fun and i'm gonna
read the information one more time for
everybody at home there's four teams
fighting to win one million dollars
that's tomorrow 1 p.m at orleans arena
tickets at 3ice dot